okay so first up as far as the glycogen
storage diseases is von Gierke Keys
disease or type 1 glycogen storage
disease the prevalence is about 1 in
50,000 to 100,000 births
it's inheritance pattern is autosomal
recessive as they all are all the
luggage and storage diseases that's it
that is the enzyme that's deficient is
glucose 6-phosphate ace 46 pas which is
in the liver in the kidney the
gluconeogenic tissues laconia genic
tissues and note that that that enzyme
glucose-6-phosphatase is not in the
muscle and other tissues it's only in
the gluconeogenesis years though the
deficiency is primarily seen as
glucose-6-phosphatase deficiency it can
also be the g6 PT 1 which is the
transporter that takes g6p and takes it
into the ER lumen from the cytosol if
that doesn't sound familiar then
definitely watch the video about the
visuals when it comes to gluconeogenesis
so so yeah so this is like type 1a and
type 1b depending on the specific
division see although this is typically
what people consider when talking about
the deficient enzyme in monarchy's
disease
now the glycogen it's gonna build up in
this disease but the structure of it
will remain normal because we're not
affecting the branching of glycogen so
there are some clinical features severe
fasting hypoglycemia which is probably
the the most important feature some of
the little like three stars next to that
it's super important and it's severe
that's an important aspect of it
hepatorenal megali so enlargement of the
liver and of the kidney okay so that's
pretty important and then we've got half
for lactating Nia hyperlipidemia
hyperuricemia and ketosis is all are
important but those first two are like
ultra key okay so what's the the
pathophysiology how how is it that those
features show up let's scroll down a bit
okay so all all of these features are
basically based upon the buildup of
glucose 6-phosphate in the liver and the
kidney okay
and that g6p can go to multiple spots so
first up we have to recognize that a g6
pH deficiency would mean that this
reaction right here is not going to
happen or not going to happen to a large
enough extent as it should so that means
that glucose 6-phosphate cannot be
turned into glucose and so glucose
6-phosphate will build up and we won't
be able to create glucose from glucose
6-phosphate so that first that first key
feature of the severe fasting
hypoglycemia is due to the fact that GU
canadensis won't be able to happen right
this is a good energetic step and that
gluconeogenic step can't occur so this
this means that during fasting which is
when Google New Genesis happens more
stimulated by glucagon that's not gonna
be happening we're not gonna be able to
make this glucose in the liver and the
kidney so maintaining normal blood
glucose levels while fasting is is not
going to be possible alright or at least
is going to be compromised so that's
going to result in fasting hypoglycemia
and so that's going to be a low blood
glucose level when fasting so less less
insulin will be released to insulin is
works as a growth hormone so there'll be
less growth retardation and puberty will
be will be delayed
also as a result of fasting hypoglycemia
some of the symptoms over here paleness
fatigue headaches nausea etc okay so
that's the most important feature and
that's it's pretty clear to see why
right because that gluconeogenic step
will not be able to occur so glucose
will not be able to be made to be a cook
when a Genesis in the liver and kidney
okay
now that also means that glucose
6-phosphate which would have been turned
into glucose is gonna build up okay and
that's the the key to all these
different features so we already
mentioned this one
jot that one off the list so Luke law
6-phosphate is gonna build up and we
just said that this is happening in the
liver and kidney okay so where can that
glucose 6-phosphate go well it can go
this way right to glucose 1-phosphate in
back to glycogen via vicodins in base in
fact a buildup of glucose 6-phosphate
actually goes through and stimulates
glycogen synthase so more of it will be
made and it inhibits glycogen
phosphorylase because glucose
6-phosphate is an indicator that there's
a lot of glucose which stimulates
glycogen synthase and and inhibits
glycogen phosphorylase or more will be
synthesized less will be break broken
down so that means that glycogen will
build up in these tissues that we just
mentioned delivering the kidney and
actually is the result the result of
that is the hepatorenal megali alright
so we'll have an enlargement of the
liver and in the kidney and the
enlargement of the liver and kidney can
cause margin at the loom primarily can
cause like the abdomen to protrude a
little bit it'll kind of extend out okay
so that is had or renal megali there
okay so what about hyper lactate amia
well it's also due to the fact that
glucose 6-phosphate is building up so
with six fox make and go through
glycolysis right so
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and all the
way through to pyruvate and a bunch of
pyruvate means that it can that has
multiple fates it can go over to lactate
and so lactate can build up and so we
can have hyper lactate emia
so a bunch of lactate in the blood and
that can lead to lactic acidosis and
this is due to an issue with metabolism
so with metabolic acidosis okay so
that's the explanation for Hyper
lactating yeah so what's the story
behind the hyperlipidemia well we just
mentioned that we that if we have a
bunch of glucose 6-phosphate we can go
all the way down to pyruvate so some of
that can also go over to
you